olympiasiege den entschieden
[Musik]
marie-theres nadig der erste bayerische
skistar der schweiz
sie gewinnt an den olympischen
winterspielen 72 in sapporo zweimal gold
[Applaus]
es ist der beginn einer zeit wo
skifahrer helden werden und jedes kind
in der schweiz fällt man will sein wie
die idole auch ich gehöre zu dieser
generation
[Musik]
doch wer kennt heute von den jungen
tätern müller oder friedrich schneider
mitgefahren bin ich deiner mit einer
party
[Musik]
was ist geblieben vom glanz der
vergangenen tage wie war das damals als
alle spuren und was ist heute
[Musik]
sportgeschäft neuartigen den
flumserbergen ich bin bei marie theres
nadig
früher hing sie bei uns daheim als
poster sie seit die maximiert marie
theres sei zuvor nimmt für sie seit sie
nicht mehr die trainerin ist uns
funktioniert hilft weiter ihrem bruder
thomas im geschäft am liebsten sei sie
unten im keller
ich habe seit ich will also wie schnell
forderungen und die nähte so verhält
kann von den autoren als jüngstes von
fünf kindern ist weiter in den
flumserbergen aufgewachsen
sie sei schon immer ein bilder hock
gewesen sagte bruder und der liebling
des vaters der schnee lag ums haus und
skifahren war selbstverständlich gehabt
haben
das ist eigentlich natürlich freiheit
verlost mit den ich nie daran dass ich
für mich freiheit sie hat der pioniere
der bildungsforscher auction studio
scheißegal es anders sein ist etwas
gruseln falschfahrer schon dann tragen
wenn sie sich hier denn passiert aber du
hast freiheit
heute sagt sich messen mit anderen habe
er nichts bedeutet sie haben nur draußen
sein wollen
ich weiß ich habe erst arena ohne aber
zu jung sie bekommen bei dem hoch ybrig
ist dass die schweizer meisterschaft
oder bio deutsche einige seht ihr das
kann ich nur mal zwei angestellte wo ich
einfach durch deine dürfen durchfahren
das ist ein schönes 1972 im japanischen
sapporo dann die überraschung marie
theres nati-coach zweimal olympiagold
mit 17 jahren nicht gab es damals noch
nicht doch meine eltern haben mir von
diesem fernseher ereignis erzählt die
junge mathematik schlägt favoritin
annemarie pröll aus österreich und
beglückt die schweiz eine woge der
begeisterung die dicken zweite viel geld
dabei durch das ganze feld
ich begann für die pressekonferenzen
denkt warum frauen ist und sein wenn ich
die nächsten zwei spiele da geht nicht
so schnell wie es ist und dass das nicht
speziell wurde dreimal der bevölkerung
sind sie die schnellste zeit langsam ab
so sind wir dann einfach ich kann
einfach nicht ich kann nicht ich bin
nicht vorbereitungsfahrt die olympia
delegation wurde von volk und bundesrat
empfangen
viermal gold und zahlreiche medaillen
die spiele gingen ein in die geschichte
als die goldenen tage von sapporo
[Musik]
weiter wurde zum medienstar und tappte
gleich in die falle
vor laufender kamera konnte sie vor dem
bundesrat kaugummi das kam schlecht an
[Musik]
ein jahr später machte das schweizer
fernsehen eine homestory beiden atx
liebe dich ich halte ihn schon jetzt die
daumen für das nächste ski rennen
ich wohne in einem bergdorf und drei
meter von sie einmal kennen zu lernen
können sie mir ein autogramm schinken
[Musik]
viel zu jung sei sie damals gewesen um
überhaupt zu begreifen was mit ihr
geschehen sagt marie-theres nadig heute
[Gelächter]
die große wenn ich jetzt bin ich jetzt
vieles mit macht in dem ich auch im
vordergrund stellte maschinen mit ihm
einig könnte so unklar
die hätte ich sicherlich auch meine
mitarbeiter bernhard russi und dass ich
dann auch das hervorragend ich werde das
nicht ich hatte es nicht wenn ich
einfach nie ich bin ein star wider
willen das war mir so nicht bewusst
finanziell seien weg nicht immer einfach
gewesen sagt michael nadig
denn aufs geschäft einer erfolgreichen
skirennfahrer den haben den
flumserbergen niemand gewartet
die und wintertouristen waren auch
damals genauso wie heute
umkämpft
[Musik]
ein paar berge weiter südlich treffe ich
am pistenrand die erfolgreichste
schweizer skifahrerin aller zeiten
vreni schneider training schneite das
ist für mich jugend in den 80er jahren
die welt war in ordnung und vreni
schneider siegte
doch diese zeiten sind vorbei in jeder
hinsicht doch nur überfordern und auto
stellten sie das mädchen lernen und aber
meiner schulklasse erkannt verkaufen
mutterland 80 prozent sind schlitte
parteilos richtigen und das ist
natürlich schlecht schlafe schlacht sich
zieht ein schlichterspruch
immerhin dieses jahr gab es wieder
einmal richtig schnee weg gewesen
vreni schneider hat in all meine ski
snowboard und rennt schule gemeinsam mit
ihrem mann marcel meinert sie den
betrieb
daheim in elm ein geschäft zu eröffnen
als skistar das war schwierig doch
darüber will trainer schneiden mit mir
nicht reden es sei nun alles geregelt
sagt sie könntest du sie
[Musik]
für den schüler aus dem kanton zürich
organisierte skischule fröhlich schneide
ein rennen alle vom lager machen mit
[Gelächter]
aber nicht schlagen und das skilager das
gab es während meiner schulzeit jedes
jahr uns dabei sein war prestige sache
von dieser oberstufenschule aus
weiningen im kanton zürich sind nur etwa
zehn prozent ins lager gekommen
während wo viele sind mit beim bieten
jetzt auch ich saß also muss es sicher
gern nun muss sie dass man ein buch
reichlich weniger schlafen was einmal in
die ferien für sie zahlten perick wieso
machen
es gab wenig dienstleistungen findet
lagerhaltung höchstem niveau mit den
vernünftigen grund wo eigentlich also
heute kriege in schnitzler und
eigentlich foto gunter spitz nach dem
lernen kinder in der schweiz sollen
skifahren das ist seit 100 jahren so
gilt das immer noch auch wenn skigebiete
jedes jahr um den schnee bangen und die
alternativen günstiger und attraktiver
sind bei vreni schneider werde ich noch
tragisch sie verkörpert den höhepunkt
des schweizer skisports
damals gab es soviele die aller welt
zeigen konnten was wir eben richtig gut
können wundert mich nicht an einer wm
weil sie viel kraft und war nie der
datum verschiedene zu heute dank ja so
hitze installiert wenn sie noch mal
glück kamen 2 heißt war noch verletzt
ist das sind sie mit platz 15
sind sie an der alemannia das sind das
sind sie produkte c6 g gold vroni das
war in den 80er und 90er jahren
sie hat fast alles gewonnen was es zu
gewinnen gibt
doch da waren auch all die anderen edeka
es firmen zur briten peter müller oder
maria walliser auf hochglanzpapier haben
sich die bilder eingeprägt
nie waren die schweizer stärker als an
der heim-wm in gramm und zahna 1987
es regnete gold und man fühlte sich
unbesiegbar
und dass schließlich ausgerechnet der
knorrige p für müller gegen den
eleganten zu bringen in der abfahrt
gewann das warten wie cool
[Musik]
das ist peter müller heute vor 25 jahren
hat aufgehört mit dem skirennsport er
ist jetzt besitzer eines schuhgeschäfts
im kanton zug
allerdings sei das mehr hobby
us-geschäft sei es den leuten nicht auf
den kopf fahren niemand mehr sagte bei
skirennen im fernsehen dieses immer
peter müller aus alles will das sei
schon lange vorbei sagt er
er ist aus seiner heimatgemeinde
weggezogen adliswil habe ihm nach dem
weltmeistertitel vier täler geschenkt
das von der miklik seither lebt er in
bar ehemalige spitzensportler hätten in
der schweiz einen schweren stand sagt
müller der mit skifahren richtig geld
gemacht hat der gelernte gärtner hat
nach der lehre auf die karte skiprofi
gesetzt
der vater habe das nie verstanden nur
geduldet hat nur einer geschlagen hat
immer eine trotzige und dass da nicht
dass sie tatsächlich mit und sich ändern
und das ist doch eine hexe
klein peter ging schon früh mit dem
vater auf skitouren in winter beinahe
jedes wochenende durch einen kollegen
ist der zufällig beim schienen- sport
gelandet auf anhieb war gut
er hat gemerkt da liegt was drin
müller ist dran geblieben und hat als
bub auf seine weise trainiert oft
alleine im bachbett und drosseln muss
natürlich dann ist noch nicht gestellt
und noch nicht so arg male la rocca und
der von ihm in love ausgesteckt meistens
im tief schnell wieder auf die beine
helfen
und dann bin ich stark bin die touren da
was brauchen die sie dir 25,6 community
wird es gemacht
mit 23 jahren der erste große erfolg
peter müller gewinns 1980 das
lauberhornrennen nach sechs jahren
endlich wieder ein schweizer
ich kann mich erinnern dass er immer
wieder kommentare einstecken musste wie
diesen aus der sendung karussell fans
mobilisieren
richtige standort oder sogar meine ganze
team gehört peter müller der grantige
hält mich denkt er ist sich treu
geblieben seien freunde - stecher kann
den früheren nur vom fernsehen sprung
meinung dass verhaftung der
zwischensprint rosenheim sehen sein
als ewiger jugend sieht das peter müller
der erfolgreichste schweizer abfahrer
blieb auch nach seinem rücktritt in der
medienpräsenz in der schweiz gibt es
keine royals dafür skistars
doch müller meint das sei nicht viel
wert in der schweiz in österreich sei
das anders
nach seinem rücktritt lief es für ihn
nicht immer rund weder beruflich noch
privat
[Musik]
ich habe keine hoffnung
so ein bisschen die ehemalige
kunstturnerin svetlana ist müllers
zweite frau sie sagt mit ihm sein sport
nie spaß peter wolle gewinnen immer noch
von den skipisten hat er sich
verabschiedet
er fährt nur noch tourenski das andere
hp hat gehabt
[Musik]
keineswegs aber du musst ist es fast 200
merkst du aufgehört hast alles versteht
ist wirklich cool
sie sagen dass es gar nicht sehen oder
verstehen reflektieren
[Musik]
wissen bietet in elm auf der skipiste
die sportschule clarus trainiert die
beiden gruppen von ex skirennfahrerin
vreni schneider flavio und florian
stehen noch ganz am anfang einen
möglichen ski karriere
[Musik]
ob es jemand aus dieser gruppe
tatsächlich der einst schaffen und sogar
identifikationsfigur werden könnte und
ja ja mein leben zu ermöglichen
der ruf war zu betrieb muss auch
professionell gemacht werden und da man
selbst reinigen professionell sehe und
vreni schneider weiß was man auf sich
nimmt ihre knie sind vom profi sport
kaputt superflache später gehen wie die
so klingt es ist wichtig dass dieser
motiviert weiß dass diese sachen mussten
weichen
doch um etwas stütze gesicht also ich
jetzt aber möchte muss sich an der
spitze
ich bin froh dass man das selber nehmen
was machen
beim skisport ist es wohl wie im
richtigen leben auch es ist nicht alles
gold was glänzt und die zeiten ändern
sich
ich bin noch mal in den flumserbergen
beim ersten bayerischen skistar der
schweiz weiter dick sie hat es mir etwas
anderes gemacht als skifahren
erst war sie denn fahren dann ski
trainerin
das stück wird dafür tweets und
schweizer schweizer schafften inkasso
internen gespielt wurde nicht ich schaue
jetzt nur das
[Gelächter]
[Musik]